okay
here we go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to another episode of
your favorite podcast
[Music]
wow
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back to river
with griffin i'm back from cabo i went
to adam devine's wedding it was fabulous
um so in this episode we're going to
talk about the wedding we're going to
talk about destination weddings
um i'm going to talk about uber and lyft
i want to briefly talk about that john
gruden situation the
raiders coach
um
i want to talk about a chappelle special
and we have a similar joke and
you know all that but welcome back
[Music]
i feel my silky voices back y'all
silky voice is back
okay first of all thanks for being here
thanks for joining ripping with griffin
once again um for the people looking on
youtube as you can see i got this
beautiful background that's from my
that's this is my hotel room in cabo it
was so beautiful but if you would like
to send me a picture that you would like
to have as a background i really got
some great pictures from people actually
so i'm gonna try to incorporate them i
might have to use more than one per
episode but this is like if you're
listening right now you gotta go watch
it on youtube too because i got this
beautiful setting and i have another
great picture with rachel on the beach
but anyway this is the one that we're
using for this episode right now riffing
with griffin and thanks for watching and
make sure you also check me out on
twitch
uh you know that's eric griffin gaming
on twitch i do that pretty much daily
and so you can check me out there make
sure you follow eric griffin gaming so
thanks for being a part of that uh and
again you know just thanks for being
here guys today's episode we're going to
talk about a lot of stuff well whatever
we're going to talk about the the cabo
wedding
i'm going to talk about uber we're
talking about john gruden
uh chappelle
and um
and i'm gonna i'm gonna do a recap of a
movie i saw on the plane uh fast and
furious nine so make sure you stick
around for that because that was
something else
but first
as you can see if you're watching you
can see this beautiful setting uh man
adam devine and my buddy from
workaholics you know he invited me to
his wedding and it was a destination
wedding
and it was at this beautiful resort in
cabo it just
i mean i feel so i we just got back
yesterday and i got to say i really feel
good i mean going on a vacation is
important you know what i mean and you
know so i'm going to talk about going on
vacation i want to talk about
destination weddings
and all that okay uh so first
first going on a vacation okay
well let's yeah let's talk about that
going on a vacation listen guys
everybody's at different levels of money
and all this kind of stuff all right so
you but i suggest you try to find a way
to go on a vacation and it doesn't like
a buddy of mine's married and he's got
like two kids
he makes a good living but you know
he's frugal so what he might do is like
he lives in la so he might go to like
orange county
and there's this hotel that has a lot of
like kid stuff
so what he does is he might go
rent a hotel room for two days
and then like you know
his kids get to play
and he's just away from work and he's
just relaxed it's affordable
but it's you know it's a form of
vacation it's a form of shutting down
and i think that's important
shut your mind down
don't think about work don't think about
whatever you're just on a rest rest and
relaxation so i know not everybody can
do not everybody can go to cabo i get
that i can i'm not going to apologize
for that all right
it is what it is but any other vacation
you might want to go to like even if
it's like a cruise ship this is a very
affordable vacation or you could find
something that's nearby it's just you
know just at all levels but i want to
use a number you have to decide like
what you want to do with your money is
really what it is i think you should
save up for vacations no matter who you
are but out of whatever walks of life
save up for a vacation whether it be a
thousand dollars whether it be ten
thousand dollars save up for a vacation
and then you gotta decide how you wanna
spend the money
i'm in la so going to cabo it's not as
expensive
uh what do you call it plane ride so
then you can spend more money on the
vacation stuff there
you know so let's say you say and this
is not for everybody i'm just using this
as a number so let's say you're saving
up ten thousand dollars to go on a
vacation there's just two of you if
there's kids it's a different thing but
i'm just saying if you're a
if you're like in a relationship or
you're newly married or you don't have
kids yet let's i'm speaking to these
people because this is what what i
relate to
so
let's say you're saving ten thousand
dollars all right you gotta decide what
you wanna do with your money and i'm
trying to figure out now like i i've
been to costa rica before and that's
that that's an affordable trip okay so
for instance i'm just saying what are
you gonna spend your money on let's say
you want to go to tahiti you want to go
to
you know you want to go to something
exotic like that bora bora you want to
go to something like that or you want to
go to something like i love beach
vacation so that's my thing i'm a beach
vacation guy i don't like being in
cities because all cities are the same
you know i went to new zealand one year
and i was like what i was like this
looks like la and so i was like you know
why am i wasting all this money to come
to a place that's just a city so i don't
like cities unless it has some old-timey
feel like some places you go in europe
you're like okay you got to like the the
history the culture that's the thing
about europe because it's so old like
you might want to go to paris and you're
going to see all that percy stuff or you
might want you know what i mean so it's
like it depends on what you want to do
if you're going for like
like you're doing a museum tour or some
kind of history tour for yourself or you
just want to see the you know the beauty
of the city i don't care about that
stuff me i'm about being on a beach
uh you know that's just me so we're
gonna talk about how if you're a beach
person too this is the thing you gotta
think about so let's say you wanna go to
bora bora or someplace like that now you
gotta think about the plane tickets
because that's gonna be a lot of the
money i'm not flying coach sorry i'm 6'3
i'm not going to be on a 10 hour flight
in coach so i got to spend more money on
business class tickets or first class
tickets whatever it might be so of my 10
000 i might spend on my vacation now
it's like
it it might be up to 3 000 a ticket so
that's 6 000 gone now you talking about
where you're gonna stay you know is it
gonna be 300 a night 400 a night plus
food is it gonna be all-inclusive you
have to figure that out amongst that the
rest of the money you have left which
would be four thousand dollars might be
a great vacation sounds great right you
know and you figure out what the cost
some people might be like they you know
you only got five thousand you still
want to go to tahiti but you're gonna
fly coach and when you fly coach to
anywhere you go you guys it's actually
affordable if you've if you've saved up
money for your vacation but for me i
need to go like that i want to go i want
to go bougie okay i'm bougie like that
but i ain't rich rich you know what i'm
saying so it's like i have to say i do
save up i put money aside like this it's
my vacation money and then we're going
to go on vacation so i did that for this
i knew i was going to this destination
winning and it was like whatever okay
all right so
if you're gonna go to bora bora it's
gonna be all now
you might not stay at like the top level
resort because you spent all your money
on plane tickets you might because there
might be a place that could be 500 a
night 700 a night sounds like a lot but
when you get there and you see the 700 a
night room and and whatever is included
in that it might be worth it you know
you might be like oh wow there's a hot
tub in the room like we had look at this
picture there was a hot tub right there
right in our room uh the beautiful view
uh the room was spectacular you know it
just was so comfortable and relaxing you
opened the blinds and it was just like
this beautiful beach view so you know
you might want you might think well i
want that that's gonna cost you more um
you might again
i think if you go to a place where it's
like
is the room service included cause i've
been to i went to costa rica one year
and everything was like the meals were
included and you could call room service
24 hours a day and that was part of your
service that's a that stuff's important
because food is expensive when you want
all these vacations because you have to
count that in too you got the room per
night and you got the food you have to
pay for it because it's all going to be
expensive you're on vacation so you got
to decide that but i'm starting to think
now after going to cabo i was like
kabul's a great vacation i usually don't
like going to places where you see a lot
of americans because then you feel like
you're there but you just got to ignore
all that and see like what you want if
you want the beach view in the beach and
the pool and the hot sun and the
beautiful margaritas and and just you
know you're there with your lady it's
like you know you could spend more money
on the luxury of it than the flights
because because a two-hour flight
it's just a two-hour flight that's not
gonna be that expensive you know and
even if you just want to fly like
economy plus
you could spend even more money on the
resort this particular resort we were at
pricey as a mother it was pricey as a
mug man okay but
it was worth it
but because we were on a destination
wedding thing the wedding package didn't
include meals so we also had to pay for
meals this vacation was expensive
i'm just telling you right now it was
expensive you know i actually wasn't
prepared for how expensive it was but i
knew it we went early because i said
this will be our vacation and i wish i
stayed i wish i had gone even earlier
and really enjoyed it
so when you're thinking about vacations
guys you got to take all that into
account like some people are like they
don't care what their room is like they
could be in a cheap room because they're
going to go do all the stuff
i'm not like that i like my room to be
fancy because i want to just be in the
room and just chilling because it takes
me like two or three days to feel like
i'm on vacation to turn my brain off
stop thinking about work stop thinking
about my podcast stop thinking about
gaming stop thinking about like what do
i got to do next to pay rent or all this
kind of stuff i just it takes me a
couple days where i'm just like sitting
here so they you know top of day three
we're just sitting in i'm on a on the
beach at you know one of these you know
whatever those things are called we got
an umbrella you know rachel's getting
seashells and i'm just sitting there and
i was like damn this is ah i wasn't
thinking about anything and i was like
now i'm on vacation
so
you know you got to determine all that
kind of stuff because i used to think i
want to go to like tahiti i want to go
to like like oh let me go furthest away
from the united states as possible just
so i could be on some exotic beach but
i'm telling you there's some beautiful
beaches and stuff right close by
maybe maybe even in the united states
there might be a great like private
resort in miami or someplace in florida
or someplace you know on whatever the
coasts are i gotta start looking into it
and uh but anyways the point is i'm not
trying to make people feel bad who don't
got any money at all i'm just saying
find find something that's affordable
for you but save up for it you know even
if it's only you can only save up a
thousand dollars all year and this is
your vacation money find something find
something even if it's like going to
disneyland and you find a great room for
three nights and you get meals and
you're just enjoying disneyland with you
you know or whatever it is it could be
like oh we're gonna go to newport beach
and we'll find some hotel in newport
beach just real swanky and make a
vacation of it but it's all about a
mindset so i do encourage that
so we went to this wedding you know adam
devon he's an a-list star you know what
i mean
so this was a fancy ass resort
i i'm not gonna be i used to think like
you know you hear the thing comics
always talking about destination
weddings you know they're like
destination weddings you know it's like
that old joke like like if you do it in
chris rock style you know what i mean
i'm actually the complete opposite i
love a good destination wedding after
going to this destination wedding i was
like i'm all about going to somebody's
destination wedding because you just
turn it into a vacation now let me tell
you the best part we were at a place
that
it's like i said this is adam devine
okay like rebel wilson was there the the
the green day drummer was there you know
what i mean like it was like it was
agents and you know people that he's
known his life i mean it was fancy it
was a fancy wedding
the room was a thousand a night
okay
but because you got the wedding discount
it was 50 off
so like i don't know if i would normally
go to a resort for that price
but i was able to go at this price
50 off
and i was able to enjoy with my lady all
of the stuff you know what i mean so
there was more money to be able to be
spent the vacation savings of like we
got massages which was like 600 for both
of us it was crazy every meal was
expensive but you know what i was like
this was a beautiful vacation i almost
feel like i want to look at the registry
of this place
and see who's doing their wedding there
like in six months and then i need to
like hit those people up on instagram
and start befriending them
so i can get that wedding discount
to go to go back you know what i mean
so
i love destination weddings like i say
it really was a good time you know what
i mean like we really had a good time
um you know there was like this other
really beautiful picture
you know of the beach here
you know
just like oh look at that just oh look
at look at look at her look at her just
rachel was just standing on the beach
looking out you know it was just
it really was a beautiful time so you
know
i suggest you make time for a vacation
guys
find a way
you can find a way so as you save up
from now if you go i want to go on a
vacation in
nine months even if you're gonna take
tell yourself take two years
open a savings account or get a jar that
you just have that you keep under your
sink
just put the money away tell yourself
every time you get a 10 bill
if you have a 10 bill in your purse or
wallet take that 10 bill out and put it
in the jar
something like that i had a buddy of
mine said he did that he was uh in a
relationship and they did that they just
took and then after a while they ended
up you know after a year they looked in
the jar and they had enough money for a
really nice vacation so i you know i
don't know i don't know what your thing
is whatever you can afford if it's
twenty dollars a month then put twenty
dollars a month away uh find a way to
save up for vacation for your own mental
health that's really
you know what i mean what i suggest all
right so find a way to do that man
all you guys and so you know i had like
i said we had a really good time the
wedding was beautiful it was such a
spectacular setting and then they had
all their wedding vows and rachel was
crying the whole time and i teared up
and it was it was all so funny
adam rake my buddy my comedian buddy
adam ray he was i've been on his podcast
he's been on mine he was the official
officiant of the wedding and he did such
a great job that a bunch of people were
like hey dude can you do my wedding you
know it was just he did a great job it
was heartfelt it was funny
you know just the setting was just i
can't tell you enough uh so anyways
there was that
all right so let's get into this though
so when we coming back
even going and coming back from the
wedding i i realized something um
guys
uber
and lyft
they're done
okay can we talk about this
can we talk about uber and lyft and all
ride sharing apps
i i need to talk about this right now um
what happened
they done man
they are done
okay so when we were going to the
airport it was early in the morning
flight
so and i live
like 10 15 minutes from airport i'm on
the west side of la so
it may have cost like 32 or something
like that to get to the airport right
and you know in in that hour it was easy
someone was available they got there in
seven minutes we got to the airport but
coming back on a sunday
at a certain time of day
man
i'm look i'm trying to get a lift
and then it's eighty dollars
eighty dollars
hold up
pump the brakes
what happened
it was supposed to be
lyft and uber
and news kind of ride sharing apps the
point of it was convenience and cost
i mean it used to be you'd be like damn
it's only fifteen dollars to get from
point a to point b that when you get
into a cab the cab might be you know 28
or 25 whatever it is and so that's the
reason why you were doing it
they running a game on us now those days
are done man they're done it was 80 to
get from lax to where i live 80 and i
hear everybody talking about this now
everybody's like damn what's up with the
uber prizes it's hard to get uber you
know what
get a cab
we hopped into a cab
right at the airport and it was way
cheaper than it was like
a third of the price that uber and lyft
were asking for the same ride
so what's the point of using them like i
don't get the point of using them and by
the way
there are so many apps right now that
you could just call a cab just call a
cab with these apps curb taxi cab hail
there's so many of these apps now i'm
i'm about that now you know because if
it's going to be around the same price
at least these people are professional
like i don't know what happened
throughout the pandemic and all that so
maybe it's the same thing the service
industry has been decimated people don't
want to do that job anymore you know the
people that were like
the first of all
people that a lot of people that were
driving uber and lyft they didn't want
to have regular jobs anyway so there are
people that take it serious they were
making good money doing that because
they took it serious like a job like a
cab driver it's a job it's a profession
so they took it as such and they were
like oh this is great and there are some
people who were just like i don't want
to work in nine to five i want to work
on my own schedule and they did this and
they just kind of like were like okay
i'll do it sometimes but they don't
necessarily take it serious or they
didn't think of it like a profession or
a real job or career they just were
doing it because they were down on their
luck or you know so they don't really
have respect for the job all those type
of people that were doing it
they got their free money from the
government so they were like why do i
want strangers in my car why do i want
to put wear and tear on my car when i
can get this so now there's no drivers
you know what i mean there's nobody
driving you can't get a driver or it's
like they hit you with this like surge
fees oh it's so busy they think they're
the only game in town quad has this cap
man
get a cab
i'm telling you you search for a taxi
right these days and look look at the
price seems to be comparable but at
least these people are professional you
know what i mean this is a it's a real
you know so
i don't know i flipped it because before
i used to be like
i'm not doing
cabs anymore you know they act like
they're doing you a favor it's dirty i
used to have all these things about like
why i didn't want to get into a cab
now i'm like
we can't even get an uber or lyft or
whatever and then you guys go on your
phone right now look up right just go
ride share in your apps a thing and you
will see that there are actually tons of
ride sharing services that are out there
you know but just uber and lyft are the
main ones you know what i mean they're
just the main ones but i don't know if
this gonna last
because
it's a racket you know what i mean it
really is a racket
now
because you know you're sitting and you
think this is the only game in town and
you look at the thing and you go oh man
like i want to be more comfortable in
the back of a corolla as opposed to the
back of like most likely a prius cab
right there's no difference you know the
difference now is
the cab is reliable and the cab is
cheaper
so
you guys i'm telling you out there right
now are you somebody that ubers and
lyfts all the time you might want to
look into checking the prices of a cab
like just grab a cab app and start
comparing because i do that anyway with
uber and lyft i go okay lyft is 80 let
me go check uber you know 75 dollars and
you know and then they have this other
thing
like at the airport at lax you could get
uber black so like if you get an uber
black they let the uber black people
pick you up
at the terminal
right so i was like all right it looked
like it was like the same price because
of the surge pricing the uber black i
couldn't even get one like there's like
the people that drive over black now
they they not even doing it as much
anymore the people that got like a
pseudo fancy car that they're using for
uber black they're not even you can't
even get it so it just was like we're
sitting there waiting 20 30 minutes and
i'm like what is this so we just walked
over to the other area and we got into a
cab and then when i saw the price
difference i was like well i'm done
that's it sorry uh you know they lost my
business you know it's like it used to
be this cool convenient thing
that
the main point of it was it was
convenient and most importantly it was
affordable more affordable than say
taking a cab
those days are done
it's limited now i i just think that
you know uber and lyft y'all got uh a
ways to go man a ways to go
so that's my bitchin with griffin ranch
about that oh by the way you know what's
something else that i thought about in
terms of something being a racket you
know what i think's a racket tube guys
destination weddings by the way
like i said earlier i want to go on
destination weddings i love them but uh
i think it's also a racket and i'm gonna
tell you why so you take someone like
you know a famous person like adam or
you know somebody that's
lives a good lifestyle blessed life so
they can go to a fancy place like this
and be like hey i want to have my
wedding
but man
he also had to pay for the wedding
that's a racket i'ma tell you why he had
like 100 people at his wedding maybe
more so that's maybe like 60
groups
you know what i mean it was maybe like
because it's a couple some people came
by themself you know because their
significant other was busy or whatever
it is like that you know and then it was
you know you had extra
people there so you had like 60 groups
that say right
even if it was 50 groups
people are staying
three four days
you know just for the rooms alone it's
like 2 000 let's say minimum 2 000
per group
for just the hotel
the food guys if you stay in that long
the only place you can eat is at the
hotel let me just tell you that it's
another 1500 to 2 000 okay if people get
massages whatever the stuff they're
buying drinks all the stuff they were
doing so you're talking about
per group it was probably an average of
like four thousand dollars
okay
this resort
made they probably made 200 to 250 000
off this wedding
and charged them for the wedding
what
did that sound like a racket to me
because to me it seems like you should
go to the people and be like okay i'm
gonna have if i have a hundred people at
the wedding the wedding should cost this
amount if i have 200 people it should
even be less amount because
the place is making all this money off
your wedding
i don't know what y'all think of that
tell me in the comments
[Laughter]
all right next what else that i want to
talk about today oh i did i wanted to
talk about
this um
situation with john gruden you guys know
who that is he is the los
vegas raiders head football coach he
signed a 10-year 100 million dollar deal
it's been an iffy so far uh you know he
was he won a super bowl way back in the
date and he was out of football for a
while because he was just an analyst
well recently a email surfaced from him
from 2011 where he he sent an angry
email and in his email he was making
some very
sort of derogatory comments
towards a black executive okay
and
now it comes you know 11 years later
it's come out and now he's getting
dragged
okay how do i feel about this
it's layered two things all right first
of all i want to say
like
a lot of people say things
in
private that like as a comic i say
things to other comics like if you heard
me and andrew santino if we were ever
recorded some of the things we say
it's terrible and i think we all have
been in this situation you know you have
but here's the thing
when that private conversation goes
public
you do have to answer for it if you've
made people feel bad
like you can say it wasn't my intentions
it wasn't this and that
you know but it is what it is now that
it's out you have to answer for that
now
how
someone should be punished or whatever
that is
neither here nor there i guess it just
depends on case by case it depends on
the what the perceived intent is or
whatever it is like that
you know but i have no problem with
people having to answer for things that
they've done it just depends on what is
the severity of like what the punishment
should be and i think that that goes too
far sometimes you know you're looking at
somebody's tweet like they tweeted when
they were in high school
you know they tweeted something 15 20
years ago
and uh you know or they just tweeted
something when they were like really
stupid you know from the ages of 13 to
18 they said something so now you know
you idiots think that they should lose
their whole life for something that they
said before as if there's no growth as
if there's no you know you know yes
it's like answer for it but i don't know
if people should lose their life and
livelihood over something that they said
when they were stupid at any age really
you know what i mean i mean i don't
think we are i don't think we are our
best moments or we are our worst moments
was this john gruner's worst moment i
don't know it ain't a good look i tell
you that being a caucasian
male
football coach in a predominantly black
sport you have to walk into that locker
room and now answer for this thing
that's out there they got to look at you
and be like yo what was that about you
know and whatever relationship he has
with them he'll be able to determine
that but the court of public opinion
they're going to be like hey man are you
a racist you know and that's the thing
do i think he's a great do i think
someone's a racist because they say a
racist comment no i think there has to
be a pattern of behavior
in their quiet moments not their extreme
moments in their quiet moments what do i
mean by that extreme moments are similar
to trolls
like these trolls in the comments when
people troll and they say something
really like outlandish well they they
think they they think that of themself
because now they're thinking well no one
cares about me or what i say so i can
say something stupid and racist it's
never going to come back to me because
they don't care they think their life is
they don't really think highly of their
life that's why they say dumb [ __ ] on
the internet you know like they don't
think they're like some of the things
these trolls say to me in the comments
and even dms if the if their boss of
their company saw that they might say
something they might think what's up
with this uh why did you say that that
seems kind of stupid and rude and
ignorant you know but you know the
trolls they don't even think past that
because they don't even think anything
of their life they you know they they
they don't think highly enough of their
life and character to think that saying
this publicly is inappropriate
it just is what it is you know what i
mean
so that's that's a troll mentality and
we all have it
we all have a troll mentality that also
in the instance of the troll mentality
you say the worst thing you possibly can
say and you always start with
looks
like a lot of troll comments i get like
when i'm gaming you know and then i say
something to these idiots in the chat
you know then somebody goes they go to
the same jokes always oh man you're 50
playing video games you're fat you're
ugly you're this you know they always go
to those things they think i don't
always get race first because i'm mixed
i'm not traditionally anything so that's
not the first thing you go with but that
is an instinct that people go with too
you know when people say like you know
they'll be like oh you know if you're in
your car you'll be like oh you see a
driver and you'll be like you you go to
the worst possible things oh it's a
woman that stupid woman asian whatever
you might say you say these things
that's your stupid troll that's your
dumb troll mentality we all have it we
say the dumbest stupidest
things that we visually see
and then
now does that make you a misogynist or
you hate women or you know you're racist
or you're you know it i don't know i
think it has to be a pattern of behavior
and i think it has to be in your quiet
moments so not your troll excessive like
like this guy was upset john goonan was
upset and he wrote a disparaging email
in hate like he was upset and he wrote
this thing do i think he's a racist i
don't know him well enough to know that
there are people that are coming out on
both sides saying like they don't think
he's a racist he's a nice man and
there's other people saying like and he
had like some some stuff so we had to
wait and see
now what i mean by quiet moments is
somebody's racist when not when they're
angry
not when they're super upset not when
they're heightened just when they're
just living steady
if somebody says some racist stuff when
they just live and steady
that's when they're a racist you know
there's nothing inspiring it there's
nothing poking them they're not
heightened they just in a restaurant and
they look over and say like what is this
n word doing here you know or you know
just in casual conversation they're like
well you know
you know uh jews you know what i mean
just if you say you know what i mean
it's that kind of stuff
i have an example that i was man i
performed comedy in syria you know i was
one of the first comedians to perform
comedy in syria when it was open you
know where and now and i'm at i remember
never forget this i meant this sort of
after party you know
and
we're at this private thing and and
these people from they're just talking
and in the casual conversation
they they said like the most
anti-semitic like it was so casual well
you know well that's you know it was
like whatever they were saying it'll be
like well you know the jews caused that
you know that's because of the jews it's
just the way they said it i was like ooh
it made me so like ooh like tensed up
but i was like let me not you know what
i mean
i need to get out of this place you know
what i mean you know what i'm saying i
mean i didn't co-sign but i just was
like listening like okay wow here we are
it that's when it gets you you know like
at a cocktail party and people are just
holding their drinks and they're just
like oh you know the blacks
that's when somebody's racist because
it's casual it's just in their thought
process
i don't necessarily think that this
email that this guy sent
was in that vein i think he was mad
you know he called the the commissioner
he was he called the person dumb and he
called said something else about the
commissioner and he was just he penned
an email he shouldn't have pinned like
he should have re-read that and been
like ooh i probably shouldn't say this
you know uh you know and he could be
racist for all we know i don't know
you know but he isn't but the but it's
like if you're racist
i find it hard to be like that means he
loves money more than he did he loves
money more than he is racist because he
went into a business that he has to work
with a lot of black people
and he's highly paid so if he's racist
and he hates black people he loves more
he loves money more than he hates bad
people why would he put himself in that
situation i don't know that that's just
the age old question and i'm sure
there's a lot of people who work with
the the thing that they're racist
towards too i know that i get it i'm
just saying it's like what a what a
dilemma right so it's like hard to like
imagine so i don't know man i just think
that
if if you i don't think you think you
should be judged on your worst moments
but after something like this surfaced
you do got to kind of take a look and be
like huh let's see now
so he does have some things to answer
for but i don't think he should be fired
i don't think she he wasn't even working
for the raiders at the time this was 11
years ago you know how has he lived his
life since you know what i mean have we
heard about incidents like this before
but it's just one of these things it's a
bad look the optics aren't good and
we're living in a climate right now
where we are really
like
we are really thinking about diversity
and we're thinking about how we treat
each other
and you know in a professional setting
like that
it's difficult to uh
it's difficult to like to not
think like that
you know i mean i don't want to be a
person that thinks like that you know i
just
i don't
i don't
go to racism first on anything
easier for me too because
you know i've lived a blessed life but
not always man i've experienced well
i've experienced some racist moments
i've experienced things you know i've
i've felt the hardships of not being a
person not being the most attractive
person in the room i think there's
prejudice in that i think that i've
experienced prejudice of being like a
person of color and like even in the
person where they don't even know what i
am trying to figure out like what to
even do with me you know so i've
experienced that stuff but at the same
time i also can look at things with a
common sense approach and be like i also
see the business side of it too there's
business in like
you know
um
whatever the choice might be it's not
always because of race it's not always
because of you know misogyny or whatever
the thing that people put out there you
know it's like with like comedy you know
it's like you think like oh
they're not booking women because
because they're women or whatever it is
and i don't that's not the first thing i
look at i you know i don't think that's
the factor because it's so funny when a
lot of the bookers at these clubs are
women you know so it's like it's weird
to me
i look at it and i go they go for them
it's also a business you know it's like
who's selling tickets who's putting
butts in the seats
um you know and it it it's so much ain't
just about being funny anymore
that you know that if it like you kind
of think that you go to these comedy
clubs and you think that comedy clubs
are cultivating comedy you think that
they're going like well we're work these
are the 17 funniest people we think
are coming through our building that we
want you to see
it's not like that anymore it's about
they are putting up people you want to
see
who do you want to see you know like you
we we we spend a lot of time blaming the
club clubs or even like network
television we spend all this time
blaming network television like they're
only showing us white
i think that they're doing research and
they're going like you only want to see
why you
you know they're showing you what you
want to see
so
you know
i think there's a that's a portion of it
you know i think it's like when you have
to look at the whole layer i don't think
we could jump to any conclusion i don't
think we could jump to like like i'm not
saying that it's always a business
choice i'm not saying that i'm not
my stance isn't ultimate either because
that's not my complete stance i'm saying
it's case by case and you have to look
at all the factors
and that's hard for people to do because
people want to jump to a conclusion they
want to say it's because of this you
know they want it to be like well no
it's because
you know it's because of racism it's
because of sexism it's because of ageism
people want it to be that because it
makes sense we can wrap our brain around
that and be like well yeah they're not
booking this because of this reason and
i'm saying it's not always that reason
even if it's a small part of it
even if there's in some cases i'm saying
it could be a part of it but that's not
always the case and i think we just got
to step back and look at things and take
a common sense approach but you know
that's not the world we live in and the
internet doesn't lend itself to that the
internet is for sensational headlines
twitter is just a headline to a news
story it's just a headline like that
tweet would be what the headline would
be then you got to delve into the
details of the story to find out what's
going on but we don't read past the
headline that's all we are right now as
a headline society and then you can say
whatever you want in that headline and
then now we're sitting here like damn
there's more to this story than this but
nobody really cares and then
and then it's so stupid that the the
next news cycle the next headline comes
out and we've forgotten about this cause
that we had for like a hot second so i
think this john gruden thing is a
similar thing but that being said
again when you say something
in private when you say something in an
email
and you put some words down that can be
misconstrued or you put some words down
that can clearly someone could be like
well you sound like a racist
uh doesn't mean you're racist but you
sound like a racist and you know and
that gets goes public
well damn you gotta answer for that
you know what i mean you gotta be like
oh listen
you know and how you answer for that i
think will be a gauge of like what kind
of person you are but you know it's hard
for all of us you know
you know i look back i'm sure i've
tweeted something or said something and
you know and as a comic and you have
jokes you know as a comic you know you
make jokes and then people you know they
come at you they go oh man you're you
this is terrible what you said you know
uh they then they they judge you on your
joke they think because like you know
for a male comic a lot of times it's you
hate women you know it's like if you
have a joke about a woman it means you
hate women you know what i mean like
it's like that's just that's just how it
goes but it doesn't even work the
opposite i mean you know it's like i've
seen so many female comics trash men on
stage i mean trash them
you know nobody's like oh you hate men
you know you don't that's not the first
thing they jump to we just laugh a lot
of times we just laugh oh that's a funny
joke you know
but for men it's like uh you know it's
like oh you hate women you know what i
mean so they're like well you're 50 of
the population can we you know what are
we supposed to talk about
you know
so i don't know
it's all in like all in the approach
speaking of jokes uh here's a little
thing i want to talk about now this is a
delicate subject this is a personal to
me
this is personal to me and
i've been i've been contemplating if i
wanted to talk about this but i will
so
i've been doing a joke now for about
three years maybe longer because i know
i did it in in canada like a year before
the pandemic even so i know i've been
doing this joke for about three years
i do it at the comedy store all the time
i've been doing on the road all the time
and i make the same reference that
chappelle makes in his new special
impossible [ __ ]
that is a reference i've been making now
for three years
so
i just want to put this to rest this is
for my fans not for chappelle fans
chappelle fans don't care about me they
don't know who i am anything he says
becomes doctrine anytime chappelle makes
a reference
it now is that's chappelle's and no one
else can come up with the same thing
and so
i'm just letting you know it's something
called parallel thinking with uh comics
you know if you're delving in the same
subjects if you're it you know you could
come to certain conclusions and we came
to the same conclusion
it's just parallel thinking i in no way
think chappelle i don't even go in this
i don't even travel in the same circles
as chappelle so i you know i've met him
a few times i've seen him at the kami
store a few times i've been on stage you
know you know you know i'm saying like i
i've seen the dude around but not like
to the point where i'm in the same
circles he don't got my number i don't
got his it's like that you know this
guy's one of the greats i admire him i
admire the way his brain works i admire
his like you know his bravery about
tackling things i'm not always a fan of
how he puts things together like i'm not
a fan of him doing all these specials i
think that they're just it's it's just
like he's just like his fame has just
gone to the point where he's like well
let me put all this out i think a lot of
these things
could have been taken taken some more
time to them
or or what do i mean to say like they
don't all have to be
like specials you know they don't so now
because there's a lot of comics talking
about these issues there's a lot of
comics making fun
and you know making jokes about these
things so now chappelle does it in seven
specials in three years so now if you've
been talking about any of those topics
all of a sudden now you can't talk about
them because he did it so now it's like
and and he's the most famous comic with
the most views on netflix for his
specials so now these issues that he
talks about there he they belong to him
according to
the
comedian the comedy court of public
opinion you know what i mean and this
has happened twice to me now with
chappelle so anyways i'm just so that's
when i'm just putting it out there just
being like i have to now retire my joke
but i was proud of it i thought it was
really funny the way i did it yeah i was
going to show you me doing it but i
couldn't find a good you know clicks i
don't record myself like that all the
time but i'm just going to tell you what
it is first of all i went to arizona in
a when the pandemic was like when things
opened up again and i went to arizona
and i have these jokes where i'm trying
to talk about transgender and i felt
like i was being supportive but a
transgender person or someone supportive
of that with that to show tweeted at me
and they were so upset at me i responded
it turned into a whole thing i let it go
but it made me think because a a female
friend of mine that was at the show
i said to her you know
i was like this is ridiculous she was
like well you she
she said to me well well you you did say
you're only uh the only ones you'll
accept are the ones that are like that
that you find attractive and i was like
i didn't say that
that's not what i said and then she said
well that's what you inferred right and
that made me think and i was like oh you
know what i think we all do that and
then i actually since have changed my
joke i've changed it i've made it about
like why are the ones we call brave
only the ones that like are passable
these are the ones we're hyping up the
ones with money the ones that are
attractive it's all about pretty
privilege you know i've changed the joke
and i've made it about this and i feel
better about it but anyways coming to
the joke about impossible [ __ ] my joke
is and i'm gonna put i'm saying it on my
podcast for my fans and the people that
are hitting me up a lot
people that have seen me for three years
and watch chapel special are hitting me
up comics i know are texting me like yo
dude uh did he buy that from you and
everybody's saying this kind of stuff
and i'm like yo yo no i i i am not
accusing chappelle of anything at all
it's just parallel thinking but he is
way more famous than me so that's now
his reference and i have to let it go
because if i do it anywhere else now
people are gonna say oh man you stole
that from chappelle so that that's i'm
putting the joke to rest so anyways
so i you know i i'm talking about pretty
privilege and i'm talking about um you
know leading up to like normalizing gay
lesbian and transgender we have to
normalize it you know and i i have some
jokes about it i'm making fun at the
same time too and then but i say you
know it should be like milk because you
know like i think the transgender
community needs a commercial this is my
joke i said the transgender community
needs a commercial like milk remember
when milk was uh
it wasn't a company it was just like
drink milk because they were like we got
to get this milk off the shelves and it
helped sell milk so i was like we need a
commercial for transgender i think it
should be like burger king it'd be like
impossible [ __ ]
you know it looks and tastes like real
[ __ ]
and then there'll be testimonials this
ain't real [ __ ] you know that was my
joke
you know it'd be like uh you know what i
mean and i was really that was my
favorite part of it too was when i say
that when i go there'll be testimonials
this ain't real [ __ ]
shut up this and then there'll be some
guys that will be like this ain't real
[ __ ] but anyways you know i'm
butchering my own joke but i'm just
saying
i did it differently i felt my version
was way more positive too
it just came off like you know it was
fun it's a fun moment that i was doing
and i always got a great response
because it's a funny joke you know what
i mean i just think it's fun i'm proud
of it i think it's funny so chappelle
made the same reference not in the same
way he just made the same word reference
he put the two words together impossible
[ __ ] making the reference that it's
like fake meat you know making that
correlation i heard andrew schultz say
this on his podcast too when he was
talking about elliot page you know he
was talking about elliott just you know
he probably got that impossible meet i
heard so when i heard schultz do that i
was like yeah this is a reference that
if you're if you're a smart person and
you like you know delving into things
and finding little correlations and and
little analogies to to make your joke
hit hard uh you know exaggerated form of
of saying things you could come up with
the same reference to and that's what
happened so
i am no longer going to be making an
impossible [ __ ] reference it was now
retired
and it is what it is
uh i always tell young comics my advice
to you is do not fall in love with your
material because this is what happens
you know it's whoever gets it on tv
first it's their joke it is it just is
what it is
it's a long-standing rule
you know but there's so much see before
was easier because not everybody could
get a special not everybody could be on
tv not everybody can put their stuff on
youtube you know what i mean
it just became a thing so now i'm
starting to think for myself too that i
just need to start recording myself at
shows stop worrying about saving stuff
for a special and just put my comedy out
there for the to be consumed because
then i would have had it it would have
been like a thing where i'd have been
like uh oh look at this guys i did this
a long time ago but but this this is for
my like i said this is for my small fan
base i appreciate you guys that are
hitting me up because people have been
hitting me up in the dms going yo man
he doing your joke you know that kind of
thing and i just want to put that to
rest that is not what happened at all
uh it's just parallel thinking the guy's
brilliant and i feel proud that like i
ca we came to the same thing you know
what i mean i feel like you know i feel
i'm a smart dude man you know what i
mean i'm common sense smart and i also
like pushing the envelope if you ever
see me live i like pushing it i like
saying outlandish things because i want
to see if i can make it funny that's my
goal i want to see if i can make it
funny i want to see if my perspective
about things because i like to [ __ ]
about things like to complain about
things you guys know because you're
always telling me still complaining
griffin but i like to complain and i
like to make it funny i think it's part
of my brand so when i talk about stuff i
might talk about a deaf person and i'm
gonna try to make it funny i might talk
about a fat person i'm gonna try to make
it fun i'm gonna try to make you
understand that i don't hate these
people i'm just trying to make something
funny and i am sensitive to making it
like palatable almost sensitive to
making it like you know
i don't want people to think i hate
anybody i don't want people to think
that so i don't necessarily change
myself but if if enough people say hey
you hate women or you hate this i do
take that in and be like well can i say
this differently where they don't think
i hate them but that's the last thing i
want to talk about with the chappelle
thing you know i don't like the term
transphobic
and i had to look it up because at first
to me i was like transphobia doesn't
mean like so you're afraid of trans
because i thought phobia was fear you
know so it's like so everybody i tell
jokes about does it mean i'm afraid of
them so if i talk about white people
does it mean i'm afraid of white people
that was my thought process at first but
then i looked up the joke i'm not the
joke i looked up to the oxnard
definition of transphobic and it says
dislike of or prejudiced against
transgender or transsexual people well
by definition
that definition makes sense i just don't
think the that term
i don't think that term lends itself to
that being the correct definition of it
because when you look up the word phobia
it means an extreme or irrational fear
or of or aversion to something
so
i don't think when somebody does a joke
about a transgender person they have an
extreme or irrational fear they just
think this is funny
now they might have an aversion to it
but i don't necessarily think that's bad
you don't have to like everything
somebody does and you know you make a
joke about it because you have an
aversion to it that's why you're making
the joke because you don't understand
and that's the point of the humor but
this idea that like if you make a
transgender joke it means you dislike or
you're prejudiced
i mean
come on man everybody everybody can be
made fun of
everybody can be made fun of but so i
understand you can see you know
chappelle's body of work of all these
specials he's done for netflix if you
want to come to the conclusion that you
think he hates transgender people as a
comic i don't think that but also as a
comic i can see how
uh like after a while you go you're
still talking about this
you know what i mean so you you still
going on so so i don't think he thinks i
don't think he hates but i understand
why
there are people that think
why you still talking about this if you
don't if you don't if you don't hate
them that's the conclusion they're
jumping to and i don't agree with it i
don't agree with it and i don't like
this language that's being used i just i
really don't i don't like the term
transphobic i wish there was a different
i wish there was a different um
word for the dislike of prejudice
against transgender transgender
transsexual people i wish there was a
different word
than than using phobia because phobia
again is by oxford definition and
extreme or irrational fear
an extreme or irrational fear i don't
think when you're making jokes about
transgender people i don't think you're
fearful or hate
you just think it's funny
i mean
some of it's funny
you know you can find some funny in this
um
it's a matter of like are you being mean
are you being insensitive
which those things can be funny to some
people you just have to decide what kind
of message you want to come across
you know i think i think the challenge
and the challenge i like to take on is
how can i make
this not come across like i hate but
come across where you can understand the
common ground of seeing the humor i
think that's the challenge of a great
stand-up comedian you know and so you
just have to decide for yourself if you
think um
people have pulled that off or not
all right so but again once again this
was just for my fans impossible [ __ ] is
now retired from my joke set
and i really just wanted to like talk
about it because again i thought it was
you know when i came up with that i
thought it was really funny i was like
oh that's funny i got the analogy and
then i would worked on it to try to let
me find a way to make this fun i don't
want to come across whatever whatever it
is i just think it's funny it's a funny
joke the way i did it and
for all the people that have seen me do
that
thank you for sending me messages and
thank you for watching but i'm not in i
don't fall in love with my material
you know what i mean i'm i we we're done
so that's it for that so thank you for
for the people hitting me you don't got
to hit me up anymore i know you know
what i mean that's the thing other thing
i'm saying too i know it's over okay
all right last thing i want to talk
about is
guys i was on a plane
um
and
oh wait oops oop that's not what i
wanted to do
that's not what i want i didn't want to
get rid of myself what just happened
right there how did i do that oh here i
am guys
[Laughter]
so funny um
no not john gruden that's not what you
want to do
come on get there get there here it is
yes for the people listening you don't
know what's happening but for people to
watch and they're like what are they
doing i'm a one-man show i'm doing this
again i went on vacation so when i came
back i i couldn't link up with wigs but
shout out to wiggy thanks for still he's
still involved guys don't worry
i saw fast and furious 9 on the plane
and i have to talk about it
we need to recap fast and furious nine
i what a like
this is the most
this franchise is the most ridiculous
franchise like i can't suspend my it's
so campy and fun by the way i'm not
saying like oh this is terrible don't
watch it you just gotta know you
have
a lot
of suspense of disbelief like you have
to suspend your disbelief when you watch
this show
that this movie to the umph degree so
first of all
let's recap
so
i don't even know what happened to seven
and eight okay and charlize the ron's
been in like two of them like she's just
some sort of like bag i don't know what
they leading up to
all right and spoiler alert guys by the
way spoiler alert if you haven't seen it
by now i don't really care you know what
i mean that was june 25th if you haven't
seen it i don't care this is some
ridiculous stuff in this movie okay so
first movie mo opens up like first of
all how do street racers from east l.a
turn into
international spies so that's what's
happened from one to nine
and apparently you know this street
racer from east l.a i think they're from
east wherever they're from but they like
street racers you know you know what i
mean their father was a you know
you
all of a sudden he know people all over
the world okay he for some reason not he
know people from all over the world and
he's some international spy i don't know
when this happened okay i don't know
when in the franchise he got his spy
license okay but that's where we're at
now so the movie opened up you know they
actually on the run because i'm not sure
if they're criminals or if they're like
heroes it's hard to tell but they hide
they got their kid him and michelle
rodriguez i think that's her name you
know they you know they're um
they in this on a farm someplace trying
to live a normal life you know what i
mean
so you know and they got the kid they
named him brian after the the guy you
know you know r.i.p to uh
uh
paul walker you know so they're like you
know they make a reference to his
character you know what i mean
uh so you know that that is what it is
you know what i mean yeah so you got
yeah you got michelle rodriguez and vin
diesel you know they live in in this
like you know
thing you know so then of course some
people come the rest of the crew comes
tyrese and ludacris you know who are
hilarious you know they come and they're
like yo man we got a mission so
apparently in this thing there's like
some device that mr nobody who's played
by
a kirk is it kurt russell
i forget who mr nobody is played by
listen i'm looking at the thing right
now
cause there's so many people that have
been in the movies whoever one of one of
the russell's i think it is kurt russell
he's you know he's mr nobody some like
spy person you know what i mean so he's
like you know i don't know if he was a
bad guy or a good guy i don't know what
the hell happened so they so they come
so they got this new mission dom
vin diesel he don't want to go you know
what i mean he's like i got to take care
of the kid and this is my life michelle
rodriguez is like i live fast and
furious so i'm going i'm going so then
like you know dom sees a picture and he
sees like a necklace uh that it looks
like his necklace and he just makes him
decide to go so now you get this
backstory so in these like nine movies
in the eight movies previous we didn't
know he had a brother so all of a sudden
now he's got a brother and anytime
somebody has a brother it's an evil
brother and it's played by john cena
who's supposed to be his younger brother
but john cena looked like seven years
older than vin diesel okay so i was
already out on that so suspended
disbelief with that so now this is the
the brother so now they set it up where
you know
the brother
you know he a bad guy so now they all in
the jungle so they go to the jungle
someplace in like
south america or wherever the hell they
are and and he got a camaro or a dodge
like he got some fancy car
some fast car
like
this ain't a good jungle vehicular
choice this car he got in the jungle you
know she got a motorbike tyrese got some
kind of like like
armored camper with all kinds of dumb
stuff on it and and the other they got
like an suv i'm like what how do they
get these cars here you know what i mean
was this some dealership i don't know if
they brought them in this like carrier
and i don't know how they got a carrier
you know a military-grade carrier all of
a sudden because they got these
international spy connections so so you
already like how's all this happening
and so then you know they
they have to fight an army who can't
shoot it's like the a team from the 80s
nobody with guns can hit anything like
they shoot right at tyrese and they
don't hit him and he all of a sudden
kills like 25 people you know what i
mean and then like this army is chasing
them so now they're in the jungle you
know and then there's like
gunships
these gunships again the training of
these peoples this is flying these
gunships not very good because they
shoot missiles and can't hit these cars
oh by the way they also driving through
a minefield and then dom says how fast
we have to drive to avoid these mines
and so they you know they have some
calculation because they got this cute
british girl who's like a expert in math
and ludicrous there's another like
mechanical expert so they're like we
gotta go 80 miles per hour which is like
ridiculous so so the bombs are blowing
up
they're not blowing up the car
the rockets are shooting from the
helicopter they're not blowing up the
car so they sort of escaped and michelle
rodriguez got the device so there's this
device that has two parts and this is
the whole plot of the movie where they
have to like get this device because
this device can control all computers or
some nonsense like that and they have
one half of the device you know so now
they're being attacked and then the
device falls out of the hell out of the
out of the uh
the back of the bike oh yeah by the way
she like gets hit by a car and she flies
30 feet in the air and then and then vin
diesel always does this thing where he
catches people on the hood of his car
like like the [ __ ] is made of a
mattress you know so she fly 30 feet in
the air and falls on an iron
car like a car
hood and just like oh
thank you thanks for catching me like
he's an outfielder for the for the new
york yankees like it's so ridiculous you
know what i mean so all these people in
this movie never get hurt that's another
thing that like i find so ridiculous so
now he sees that it's his brother in
this jeep which is a better jungle
vehicular choice by the way so the
brother kudos to him already he not
driving a freaking
ford mustang he driving a car that you
should drive in the damn jungle okay so
now they trying to chase him now this is
when like that is the missiles are
coming and the army's trying to stop
both of them so now a plane is coming
and they headed towards a cliff right a
plane is coming and then the plane opens
up a crane and then uh john cena presses
like the nitro on his car and he does a
big jump over a a whole crater out into
nothing and then the plane swoops down
and grabs him and he flies off
really
okay
because apparently they got some super
powerful magnet all right
so that's already ridiculous so now vin
diesel got to get away and this bridge
is like this little suspension bridge
that you can't drive a car on so but he
figures out how to do it so he like
you know hits the nitro in his car this
is like later after a lot of chasing and
whatever you know what i mean and he
like somehow he hits the edge of the the
bridge
and
it catches
on his tire
and he and the car
[Laughter]
this is so stupid the car gets swung out
into nothing into the in above this big
crater and and flies him over to the
other side where the car crashes and
tumbles like 10 times the car is ruined
and then you know it lands on his wheels
and he's just like this whoo
you know what i mean he don't get hurt
and he always got a tank top on too by
the way no scratches of bruises he was
in a terrible wreck the gun ships now
he's in like u.s territory or you know
these gunships can't get him so he's
safe so now you know now the whole thing
is about him
and his brother are chasing after the
same device dom's supposed to be the
good guy john's seen his character as
the bad guy and now it's this whole
thing and then now you know they they in
london you know what i mean like they go
to london and then you know
there's this standoff between him and
his brother when you get all the
exposition of why they hate each other
because dom thinks the brother killed
the father at a race track and it's all
this nonsense and he banished him from
the thing and so like now you know he
then you know they get him arrested by
interpol
uh you know the the other bad guy with
john cena you know his father's a
dignitary or something like that so he
he has you know he's in with interpol so
you know
10 soldiers come and and take dom in the
back of a truck but then all the
soldiers take off their uh
hoods they take off their mask and it's
all beautiful ass chicks and they're led
by cardi b
even when you say it out loud it sounds
so ridiculous so they led by cardi b
that cardi b so this puerto rican chick
is in in london and she runs she runs
some kind of spy organization but this
is just that moment where it's like
let's get cardi b in the movie right so
you're like okay so dom somehow gets
away you know so now
there they go so now cut two they got
these magnets again so the bad guys got
these magnets you know these magnets
super powerful magnets that can like you
know emp you know all the equipment and
so
john cena is able to steal the other
device you know what i mean now his
escape route is he don't want to escape
in a car
okay
he's escaping by
harpoon gunning himself
from building the building and the
harpoon guns are set up already in like
five or six buildings and oh and vin
diesel by the way who's now in london
but he has his car he has his famous car
from the whole series is now in london
with him and he's driving around in this
car how the hell he get this car to
london and why did he bring this car to
london like it's not the batmobile like
what like what's the point of having
this car in london i just it didn't make
any sense to me i couldn't get past that
like why is this car in london so he
sees what his brother's doing and he
like runs up to the building and as his
brother is you know on this zip line
going from building a building on a zip
line which don't make no sense why don't
you just get in the car and drive the
hell out of the city but okay he want a
zip line from building the building vin
diesel jumps out of a window catches him
on the zip line and they crash through
another window then they have this
incredible fight where nobody gets hurt
vin diesel's head crashes through some
stuff he should have been knocked out
john cena punches through a wall his arm
should have been broken and they had
this ridiculous fight you know he throws
them out the window and they both land
on a car again which cars for some
reason in them in the movie series are
soft and they land and nothing happens
to them then there's an incredible car
chase not a pretty british girl for some
reason she's never driven a car so she
gotta get into a stick shift stick [ __ ]
shift truck
she's never driven before just got her
license or don't even have a license now
she all of a sudden fast and furious
driver and she got a chase through this
city
crashing through cars and then she got
she turns on this powerful magnet and
for some reason this magnet is like
get pulling some things but not other
things and that magnet was a whole
throughout the movie which was like
ridiculous they were trying to say well
i just bag that's so powerful
you know i don't know so you know then
they catch john cena with the magnet you
know his car comes flying through a
building and crashes into the car
because a magnet gets a truck because a
magnet got it so now they got him
captured okay so now he's captured and
then you learn why they hate each other
more and they have the exposition but
then the army comes you know the bad
guys come to rescue john cena and then
now vin diesel is all of a sudden
superman you know he's taking on 25
dudes at once and he's like doing like
you know and he's like pulling those
roof down it's like it's like what
how is he stronger than everybody just
25 guys
when did he did he take some like it's
not even a superhero movie where he got
bit by a spider for some reason he's
stronger than everybody and he falls
down into like a a a well you know what
i mean and while he's in this well he
has a flashback and realizes that his
brother didn't kill their father and he
like redeems him in his mind and you
know what i mean so now it's the big
chase by the way cut two's charlize
theron is like you know she's still in
the movie and i don't understand why she
trapped in a box and just like being a
bad [ __ ] you know what i mean and then
like you know she i guess she like
seduces the other stupid bad guy to be
so they could be together because you
know and they set it up this you know
vin diesel says to his brother are you
sure you could trust these guys so that
like put the seat in your head of like
oh they gonna get back together and of
course john cena gets double-teamed you
see that truck right there this truck
right here you can see if you're
watching on youtube so this big truck
and so now they've stolen both
merchandise both parts of this thing
that can control all the [ __ ]
computers okay cut to michelle rodriguez
and the other girl whatever her name is
uh let me look for her name jordan she
plays mia
jordana you know you know they beautiful
you know and they go to tokyo because
they got some clue from mr nobody and
then the asian guy that got blown up two
movies ago he didn't really die because
mr nobody saved him and he also raised
this girl who's a badass ninja so these
three girls beat up all these guys i
don't got a problem with that in movies
i can suspend my disbelief enough where
it's like yes this beautiful model chick
who's 110 pounds can beat up a grown ass
man
10 grown ass men okay i don't care about
that you know you suspend your disbelief
in that i've already given myself over
to that i don't care so they have this
big fight they beat everybody up
and you get the story of like why he's
connected and how he survived which is
all ridiculous so now you know now they
gotta stop so so now for some reason
there's a satellite being launched into
the sky so they also cut to
these later these three nerds are in the
movie and they and they have a pontiac
fiero that they put a rocket on and
they're doing some dumb experiments i
don't know why they were in the movie
just to show that they had this rocket
ship or whatever they were trying to
build you know it's gonna be important
later so now there's satellites a
satellite that's going into the sky that
this device is going to you know control
every computer in the in the world so
they're going to run the world you know
so they have to stop that device from
uploading and they got to stop this
satellite so somehow they have some
military-grade plane that they put a
pontiac fiero on the roof
with a rocket on it and they launch it
into space
so
tyrese and and ludicrous are now in
space in a pontiac fiero that's got a
rocket on it so they gonna go stop the
uh
the satellite so they're now space
travelers so they're in space okay and
then while
this big bus
is crashing through europe and you know
of course they double they they they
they turn on john cena so now he becomes
a good guy and then there's this whole
big ridiculous
car crash chase scene
drone
rocket ship thing where you know you
know once again dom catch like john cena
goes flying off the truck and then you
know
vin diesel catches him on on the hood of
his car again the mattress hood and
everything's okay and then you know of
course they saved the day
absolutely ridiculous
it's you know i watched it from
beginning to end because it is what it
is it's fun it's campy but it is
the most ridiculous
like i i just
it is the most ridiculous look look if
you like me recapping movies like this i
would be more than happy to like to do
it again i mean you know other movies
that have already come out you know i
mean or whatever it is but just like
this was just it was just so
it just
i don't even know guys
you know what i mean like
it's so nonsensical
that you know
and then and by the way it's going to
keep going because charlize theron
survives at the end of the movie like
you think she dies because you think
she's flying this plane that is trying
to blow up dom
vin diesel and then you see a moment
where he somehow figures out how to like
you know get in this truck that's
tumbling
you know what i mean they had magnets in
the car
that somehow turned the truck over but
it's still going 100 miles an hour down
the street on its back and it's tumbling
and dom gets in and he you know now he's
controlling it you know he's driving it
then he finds a way to turn it and then
you know at a cliff where this this
drone plane is coming where you think
she's flying it and then things go
flying in the air and you know it blows
up the plane in the truck and he lands
superman superman position outside the
truck like who did that so it was just
like what and then of course you find
out it's a drone and she comes walking
out the drone thing like oh and she
survived so you know that means this is
going to be part 10.
part 10.
what this movie is missing honestly in
the beginning of the movie is previously
on fast and furious so we can get caught
up as like what's going on who's who why
is this happening you know what i mean
just give me a previously on and then
i'll be able to be like follow this
but fast and furious is the most campy
ridiculous
like franchise for it to still be going
because also like helen mirren shows up
out of nowhere who's this like
international british like thief and she
knows dom you know like how do they know
each other you know what i mean like
when did he have time to meet
international spies and international
thieves and stuff when he was a mechanic
and race car driver in east l.a somebody
explained it to me but anyways i will be
watching part 10 because at this point i
got to know how this ends i got to know
what's going on in this ridiculous
franchise
all right guys
this has been another episode of riffing
with griffin uh i want to thank you for
being here once again make sure you
check me out on twitch
uh eric griffin gaming i do that daily
this has been episode 155
you know thanks for being here as always
i appreciate your support
and i will see you next week
[Music]
you